ok bechos a can of the movie contract we
are now doing the mission morning never
come so I spoke with a strategy
basically telling me that was some lady
who performed the dark sacrament and she
wants an ex-lover dad so we're gonna
down ok we're going to be that mention
we're gonna fall it's [ __ ] lighten up
Rockettes got a Markov [ __ ] oh
my calf mark ass [ __ ] never
leave wake up one final tip the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] come on in the silver blood ian
has plenty of strong drink and clean why
are you looking at me like that the dark
brotherhood oh oh I my goodness you're
really here the black sacrament it
actually worked there are better work
what I need what I need is for a lane
devoted to die I want him hunted down
and murdered like the dogs he is
I didn't know it when we work with each
other but Elaine is actually the leader
of a band of cutthroats and out oh
there's a job in some old walls and ruin
Ralph bizarre it's near Windhelm they
use it as they pay all its where they
staged a raid I want you to go to that
ruined find excellent once the rain is
dead i'll pay you in gold I've stayed up
a bit but well there is one more thing
whatever else you interested if you can
I want you to kill someone else as well
you don't have to not as part of our
deal but if you do i'll pay you even
more it's no seen fire shield in
Windhelm there's no food nice too I'll
make you I'll make occasional it's not
like we do anything important okay you
got a [ __ ] where's one hell no I can't
[ __ ] tell anymore what the [ __ ] these
places are like Ellis betch I make my
fortunate
they trust form outside
that's disgustin
I've been a bit out of
let's move it
I rascal appendages crimes against
Skyrim injured people what say you in
your defense I guess you're smarter than
can I guess wait
ok
for all the bizarre the [ __ ] is well
double star
Thank You Helen I gotta look up where
this [ __ ]
what's the pixel
ok wrong
that that are
proud of what I'm Karen there we go okay
where is this place
that yeah it should be next to the giant
pool of liquid
and
[Music]
oh it's right there I was already there
family easily is as I composition bad
time to get lost here [ __ ] hard girl
to suck it hard to war band round
fetches Orvin room
and up Jessica I like to token is on me
okay i play a lucky well surprise I'm
gonna come here Ln dupont [ __ ] you that
no one
but just getting fries ah test a test a
test
okay let's [ __ ] outta ya
it was good claim what is ours let's
claim what is ours well what you saw
receptors rarely thank you that bastard
got exactly what she deserved and I
heard about milky you have more than
fulfilled your part of the bargain
please take this as payment on this
symbol of my affection I'll never forget
you thank ya thank you
[Music]
oh you're back so how went your first
week oh very good now I need your care
of extra water little more it's Cicero
but it's worse than that he's taken to
locking himself in the night mother's
chamber and talking to someone in hushed
but who is he speaking with what are
they planning I feared so you understand
my fear dear it will be no youth like
inside the night mother's coffin they'll
never seem to check it who in their
right you're hiding